oh great thanks um I want to start by
saying how much I enjoyed this movie you
did a great job with your debut feature
how long you've been working as a
producer in in Hollywood for quite a
while how long have you known that you
wanted to make direct development uh you
know from very early on I was a producer
for a writer-director named Gary Ross
and so I had you know I was I was really
intimate as far as the you know the
inner workings of his process and so
very early on I knew I wanted to direct
and I felt suited to that it was just
about picking my spot in my time and and
finding the right story and this was it
well you've been on the set of a lot of
big movies yeah and one of the things
I've learned from talking to a lot of
filmmakers is it you know it's all about
shaving time off the day it's about not
to kink rain when you don't need one
it's a it's to find the money to make
your story so what did you take away
from working with Gary that you knew you
needed to bring to something like this
well I think for especially a lower
budget film like this one and one where
we only had 29 days to shoot it was all
about picking my battles right so I
wanted to shoot the entire movie a
certain way and there was those moments
where I had to compromise get things in
one shot instead of six knowing that
there might be another scene down the
line where I need more time that's a
good point yeah I'm always curious about
the the editing room because that's
ultimately the final rewrite yeah how I
obviously you only had so much footage
with the 29 days shoot yes how did the
film how did it go in the editing room
maybe what did you learn from early
friends and family screenings that
impacted the finished film yeah I mean
there's one thing there's one Pro to not
having a lot of time right you don't
there's only so many ways you can edit
right there's only so many ways into
each scene if you only have a few shots
per scene right if you have 30 shots of
scene there's a lot of different ways so
that's one Pro but I also find in the
editing room is where you find your tone
right it's tone of the movie that's her
music and cutting pattern and all that
stuff so we had a pretty good first cut
I was really I was really happy with it
and the people who we first invited to
see it were really really moved
by the movie so I knew I was in good
shape early on and I just had to get it
into shape as you do you know the longer
you go the the the better shape you get
the movie yet for a debut film you I'm
sure you wait what did you first when
you got to Raji and then you get Sam are
you like get the F out of here like this
is gonna be my first movie and I've just
got these two great actors right well
any time as you know you know a movie is
not really you know up until you start
shooting it's not born yet so I had the
script I knew the script came out well
and when taraji she was the first one to
sign on when she signed on I knew it was
gonna be a movie then I knew and I was
told so fortunate and out water who I
was had become friends with was so
excited that taraji was gonna be playing
her I mean she was over the moon about
it I had this couple great voicemails
from her and then you add Sam Rockwell
to that and Here I am with what I think
is a great script and these two amazing
actors and I'm just in the catbird seat
you know it's like wow these people are
gonna come to life better than I thought
oh and they're both brilliant yeah and
both of their performances are amazing
yeah the thing about making a movie
that's based on real-life events is that
you're you're trying to be honest to
what really happened
and to these people but you're also
making a movie sure so talk a little bit
about balancing that line of fact and
fiction yeah I mean luckily this is a
true story right and and most of the
movie is exactly what happened so that
was good and so it's just about and look
sometimes the story is so amazing that
you don't need to embellish as much you
know and so for me it's just about
molding that and taking the journey
through that these several weeks that
you know that this story is told over in
the film but to have the book to have
had an Atwater talked to me about it for
three years Bill Riddick to be able to
talk to me about it CPS family I had a
little documentary to watch to get their
tone and their voices and their you know
their relationship it just made it that
much easier one of the things about Sam
is I know he's a perfectionist he always
likes to listen to things listen to
voices talk a little bit about working
with Sam when he is so focused on
getting it right yeah I mean Sam is
ultra prepared just as taraji as Sam is
ultra prepared before he even gets there
so we had met a few times when I
prepping down in Atlanta he would come
down and we'd talk about it and then his
you know process of of staying in that
kind of having that reality about the
character like you said he listens to CP
he had listened to see peas radio
interviews and his ear buds between each
set up you know and so but but he has
that all he's embodied that and he's
ready for each scene and very open and
giving once the scene starts and once
you have to talk about it well I would
imagine it's you you did a great job
with threading the needle on sort of
humanizing a member of the Klan but it's
also like you're you're always walking
near the third rail do you know what I
mean yeah talk a little bit about about
humanizing sort of you know the Klan if
you will like a member yeah look I think
when any when you go into a story like
this especially pacifically this one my
first goal was to understand how an
Atwater was able to get to the sky and
change his heart and Bill Riddick right
and so from there I had to figure out
where his hate came from so I had to
know about it and I wanted the audience
to know about it right make him
three-dimensional that gives us
understanding about where his hate came
from why was it misguided right and that
that gave an Atwater a map right how to
get through it and I think maybe a map
for all of us one of the things about
taraji is she doesn't look like an and I
was so impressed with what she did
physically the way she made herself look
talk a little bit about were you that
that when you talked to her about how
were you gonna portray Ann and she you
know she obviously did transformation if
you will yeah I mean look Ann and I
talked about it as soon as taraji signed
on it was so perfect because taraji had
has what Ann has right she has these
powerful eyes she has this powerful
voice right but she's also vulnerable
she's a huge heart those were the things
that mattered to me right as far as the
costume and her wig and things like that
that was all taraji i just let her do it
and she came to set like that and she
had the character fully fully formed I'm
always interested for example Clint
Eastwood likes to shoot the rehearsal
and then or maybe a take or two and then
he's out and Fincher likes to shoot 5060
talk a little bit about what you were
able to do on this film and what is your
preference if you could have done more
well so you know if you went with me
into the editing room we opened up the
dailies you can see I only had three or
four takes of everything that's it and
that was only because of time right and
if I hadn't had the crew I had because
of my previous relationships as a
producer I had a lot of great people who
came and worked for me worked with me on
this as a labor of love plus I had this
cast right and so everybody was so good
at their jobs that I was able to get
everything in two three takes yes sure
there were shot lists that I had that I
threw out half of every day you know and
sometimes when those problems arise with
time or you see them coming sometimes
there's a better creative solution
there's a few scenes in the movie that
we did literally in one shot instead of
six or seven which I wanted to have I
wanted to use a cutting pattern but we
ended up doing in one camera move and it
maybe came out better than I would have
expected when you're getting ready to go
on set it's you haven't started filming
it what's the scene or scenes that you
were like dreading pulling off with your
limited time frame well it's lucky for
me because I knew the script structure
worked I knew that I knew the scenes
worked I invented them with myself and
the actors so I was never worried about
getting hung up on an acting scene or
performance scene plus I had Sam
Rockwell taraji Henson Babu and hache I
mean come on
so the things that ever I ever got in
the weeds were we're big camera moves
with a lot of extras right and
somebody's out of place you got hundreds
of people need to be in certain places
those are the only things that ever
slowed me down and which is amazing
because that means I know at the crux of
my movie everything else is working you
the gas-station plays a big part there's
a few other locations and if you're
making a period film yeah talk a little
about the challenges of finding places
that actually worked yeah so obviously
this is for Durham but we shot in
Atlanta and my good friend Jeannie nopal
who had done Seabiscuit had
Pleasantville as a production designer
for me and she did LA Confidential I
mean she's a four-time Academy Award
nominee I mean a little talented a
little bit right
and we had you know very little budget
and she just stepped up for me and she
loved the story thankfully but our
relationship and so she I here's what I
knew I knew she's so precise and she's a
perfectionist and so I knew that once we
chose a location that once we got back
and she transformed it into the set it
was going to be near perfect so that was
one part of my headspace as a first-time
director that I didn't have to worry
about yeah once in a while you move a
table or a chair when you get there but
Janine is just her taste and her her
abilities were what made this movie
happen one of the things that I think a
lot of people don't realize is Toby
McGuire produced this he's turned into a
prolific producer yes and really
championing really good scripts talk a
little bit about how you how Toby came
to this and what it was like working
with them yeah so Toby I've know Toby
since Pleasantville he was a younger man
then so was I and then Seabiscuit so
I've been friends with Toby for a long
time and the one thing I always know
about Toby's he's amazing taste
so after I was done writing this and I
had just gotten taraji or I think it
might have been before taraji signed on
I sent the script to Toby because I knew
he was doing other things and I said hey
I need a writing job you know before I
get this movie made well he called me a
week later and had me down there we
talked and he said he wanted to produce
this movie too so with his taste and he
liked it I knew I was in good shape
what's interesting is that as I said he
did he's got a lot of interesting things
recently and Britney runs a marathon and
yeah you know anyway just did great at
Sundance it's an amazing film yeah I
gotta go congratulations on your debut
feature I cannot wait to see what you do
next thank you so much seriously great
job thank you man